[muzică]
A,
ăsta e pescuitul Delta Dunării. Asta ne
place.
>> Vă salut, dragi pescari. Suntem din nou
pe brațul Sulina. De data aceasta suntem
la sfârșitul lunii noiembrie. Vremea
este suficient de bună. Ieri am avut
soare, a fost cald. Astăzi se anunță iar
zi cu soare, dar acum este ceață, suntem
dimineața. Ieri am ajuns pe pe
brațul Sulina în jur de ora 10:30. Am
ieșit pe mai multe canale și am sondat
mai multe canale pentru că aveam
informații de la pescari că s au prins
cra pe canalele respective. Am sondat cu
sonda, am văzut doar doar caras și cât
ne făceam noi treaba pe acolo, eram pe
caraoran, cât sondam noi pe acolo, ne a
sunat un client și ne a de fapt am sunat
eu un client și el a zis că pe sulina a
prins doi crabi de 9 kg și zicok hai că
venim și noi să să sondăm pe acolo să
vedem care i treaba. În timp ce eram pe
drum, îl sun pe Harry să i spun că
plecăm pe pe Sulina și Harry ziceN pleca
că am probleme cu barca. I s a rupt
cablul de la timonerie și a trebuit să l
tragem
să l tragem cu barca noastră până la
mila 23. Și bineînțeles că ziua de
pescuit a fost gata. Undeva la 3:30 am
ajuns la Mila 23 cu Harry în spate. De
fapt, Hari era cu noi în barcă, dar cu
barca lui Harry în spate și n am reușit
să pescuim.
Astăzi am ieșit la pescuit. Suntem pe
brațul Sulina. Suntem pe apă de 3 și 5
m. Pescuim pe apă de 3 și5 m. Nu am
văzut pește aici. Au Am văzut câțiva
pești.
Ieri când am vorbit cu Mihai, este și
Mihai Mane la pescuit. Ieri când am
venit, am vorbit cu Mihai, el a spus
când a venit la pescuit că a verificat
locul ăsta și a zis: „Gabi, erau
suficienți pești, poți să te duci acolo,
nu pești mari, ci la 2 3 kg poți să te
duci acolo să pescuiești, că sigur sigur
o să l găsești."
Dimineață când am ajuns, am sondat, ne
am dus pe tot malul și în față și în
spate și am văzut doar câțiva pești pe
locul acesta pe sonar. Parcă peștele a
dispărut din zona asta, dar am decis să
rămânem aici totuși o perioadă de timp
pentru că
este ceață și nu vrem să riscăm să mai
mergem în altă parte. Probabil după ce
se va ridica ceața, dacă nu vom avea
aici nicio trăsătură, o să începem să
mergem tot peina undeva pe Mila 8.
Pescuim finuț. Am început cu momitoare,
cu cârlige de 10 și pelete de 10. O
singură lansetă, lanseta din dreapta.
este pe un cârlig un pic mai mare și pe
bilă. Mihai este la pescuit de vineri.
Ieri a scos un crap de 10 kg. Astăzi a
scos un crap de 8g. Încă nu mi a trimis
poză, dar am vorbit cu el la telefon.
Câțiva ciortani a scos ieri și să vedem
ce o să facă astăzi. Astăzi este
duminică, el o să plece astăzi, iar eu o
să rămân până marți. Mai am practic
astăzi de pescuit, mâine și marți un pic
dimineață. Bun.
Dacă o să am o să am prezentări la
momitoare, o să încep să cresc cârligul,
o să văd și ce peș prind. Dacă prind
ciortani până în 3 4 kg, nu cred că este
necesar neapărat să să schimb cârligele.
Dar dacă o să am scăpări și la certanii
ăștia, o să schimb cârligele și o să
merg pe 15. Pornesc cu finețe pentru că
vreau să provoc trăsături. După ce am
provocat trăsături cresc cresc un pic
numărul cârligelor.
Când o să mă mut pe pe la 8, dacă este
necesar să ne mutăm pe Mila 8, acolo o
să mergem pe plumb pierdut pentru că o
să pescuim pe adâncime, pe apă de 12 m.
O să mergem minim pe trei lansete pe
plumb pierdut și direct cu bilă la
cârlig. Acolo deja este făcută
înreatură.
>> Este Marius cu mine. Ia uitați
trăsătură. Știu. Hai să vedem ce avem
aici.
Da, este un ciortan, așa cum mă așteptam
pe locul acesta.
Deci, nu le am aruncat de 10 minute și a
venit
prima treătură.
Cum v am spus, pescuim cu momitoare, cu
cârlige de 10, peletă de 10 mm, siclit
aroma, căpșună
și
ia să vedem. O să încerc să mă dau eu un
pic mai așa. Să vedem dacă se vede pe
cameră.
Marius, dă mi și mie minciogul.
Nu este mare. A, ce crezi că e omreană?
Uitați și a intrat primul pește.
Omrenuță frumoasă. Hai să v o arăt și la
cameră. A venit primul pește al
partidei. O merenuță frumoasă
care a intrat la o peletă de 10 mm. Și
uitați ce nadă avem pe momitor. Nada GTA
Fishing împreună cu peletele de 5 mm.
Uitați cât de bine arată. Peletele sunt
fishme și bineînțeles că aceasta îmi
renunță. A pofti și ea la peletele, mai
mult ca sigur la peletele din
momitor și a luat automat și cârligul
nostru împreună cu peleta siclit aroma.
Da.
Și acum, dragi pescari, eliberare.
A venit și primul pește al partidei. Nu
știu ce vă spuneam înainte. Cred că vă
vă ziceam de locul lui Mihai, unde
pescuiește Mihai că este deja nădit. El
a nădit acolo. O să nădesc și eu în
continuare. Aici am dat câteva bile când
am ajuns. Bile Delta Activ de 20 mm. N o
să insist foarte mult aici pentru că nu
am încredere prea mult în loc și nu cred
că o să rămânem prea mult aici. Dar când
o să ajungem la Mila 8 o să facem o
nădire corespunzătoare chiar dacă locul
este nădit. Știți că eu v am mai spus
despre nădire. Cum facem noi nădirea?
Facem o nededi la început
de 2 3 kg de bile când ajungem pe locul
de pescuit și după care la fiecare oră
dăm câteva bile cu praștia, poate doi
pumni de bile cu praștia pe zona unde
pescuim, de fapt puțin în amonte, dar mă
rog, astea s discuții, discuții mai
lungi în funcție de prag, în funcție de
curent, în funcție dacă pescuiești în în
afară și așa mai departe. Ideea e că
nădim nădim constant locurile pe care le
pescuim. din și cu bile Fish Meal și cu
bile
și cu bile Burfood Delta Active. În
ultimul clip pe care l am făcut în Delta
Dunării acum o lună, v am spus că bilele
Delta Activ nu sunt lansate pe piață.
Între timp am reușit să le lansez, așa
că acum o să le găsiți pe site ul
nostru. Bun, gata cu vorba. Mă apuc din
nou de pescuit, o să relansez și să
vedem. Poate mai intră ceva pe locul
acesta. Dacă nu, când se ridică ceața,
am plecat direct spre Milaop. Este?
>> Da.
>> Bravo!
Dragi pescari, a doua trăsătură. De data
asta Marius e la butoane pentru că facem
un pește cu un pește. Hai să l filmez și
pe el. Mă dau la o parte să vedeți și
voi drillul.
Cum e mare?
Bravo, Marisică! Bravo!
Deci, dragi pescari, a venit primul
ciortan al partidei. Hai să l vedem.
Oho, ce ciortan, mă!
Ce ciortan! Ia uitați vă.
Ha! E chiar ciordan. Primul crap al
partidei a fost prins de Marius și
uitați vă ce
malformație are. Nici nu știu dacă așa i
a crescut sau a fost prins și i s a rupt
buza. Dar uitați vă ce buză are. N am
mai văzut în viața mea așa ceva. Dar
oricum și un pește frumos. Intrat la
peletă de 10 mm. Cum am zis, pornim pe
finețe. N am avut n a avut Marius nicio
problemă în drill. L a scos, a tras de
el. Vedeți și pe cameră că era lanseta
destul de îndoită. Și l a scos cu cârlig
de 10 fără probleme. Cârligul nu s a
îndoit.
cu momitor, bineînțeles. Așa că să nu vă
fie frică să folosiți câlige de 10, mai
ales în lunile de iarnă.
După ce după ce prindem pește, nădim un
pic.
[muzică]
Am reușit să ne mutăm. Pe locul pe care
am fost mai devreme, nu am mai avut
nicio trăsătură de crap. Am mai prins
câteva plătici și am decis să ne mutăm.
S a ridicat ceața și am reușit să plecăm
de acolo. Am venit pe locul lui Mihai
Manea pe care a pescuit timp de două
zile și a prins doi crapi frumoși.
A fost nădit locul suficient de bine
timp de două zile, iar noi acum
întreținem nădirea. O să nădim în
continuare. Pescuim, Am schimbat un pic
monturile pe două pe două lansete din
partea stângă. Pescuim pe momitoare cu
pelete de 10, cu pelete de 15, cu două
pelete de 15 și pescuim aproape de
cioate. Frânele sunt strânse aproape la
maxim. Dacă intră ceva aici trebuie să
ținem de el. De fapt, am avut o
trăsătură, un ceva a fost o trăsătură,
dar nu s a înțepat. Iar pe lansetele din
partea dreaptă am pus plumb in line și
cu bilet de 20 momentan. Atunci o să
vreau să băgăm pe cele din dreapta, cele
două din dreapta, o să vreau să băgăm de
24 pe una de dou pe una o bilă de 24 și
pe una două bile de 24. Adică îmi vin
nepânze de păianjen pe față. Bun, cam
asta este. Hai să vedem ce se întâmplă
până la final. Nu știm. Am vorbit și cu
vecinul de la de mai jos, cu Adrian ne a
recunoscut și ne a dat mesaj pe
WhatsApp. a zis că a luat un pește la 10
kg
și este aici de vineri. A zis că va sta
până marți și câțiva ciortani a luat și
el. Astăzi parcă a zis că n a luat
nimic, Marius astăzi. Astăzi nimic până
la ora asta, dar na, vedem ce se
întâmplă.
[muzică]
>> [muzică]
>> Marius, Marius, Marius. Ia uite, bă
agățut.
>> Nu s a agățat. Orică e, nu s a agățat.
Marius,
dragi pescari, a fost o trăsătură, după
cum ați văzut pe cameră, a lăsat o a
lăsat o jos. Frânele sunt strânse destul
de mult. N am putut să și ia fir. Da.
Și
na, asta e, poate vine altul. Ia. Nu,
nu, nu e de la, e de la ăsta.
Da. Deci bila de 20.
Lum pierdut.
Acum o să trecem pe bilă de 24, cele din
dreapta. Una o să băgăm bilă de 24 Delta
Active și pe una să băgăm două bile de
24 Delta Secret. Delta Secret o să dăm
un pic mai în larg și Delta Active un
pic mai spre mal. Încercăm să vedem
poate reușim să luăm ceva mai mare.
Ia fă o pe asta.
Și oricum când lansezi trebuie s o scot
și pe cealaltă că a adus o. Normal.
>> Pe bun. Ce să fac? Stai că poate e de
ăla mare, că așa face. Stă un pic pe ea.
Uite l. Îl vezi? E acolo. Stă un pic pe
ea. Bam, bam, bam, bam. Și acuma o ia pe
Ran. Ia să vezi.
Uite l, mă. Uite l. Îl vezi, Marius?
>> Da.
>> O ia pe Ran. Fii atent de nu lua o. Ia,
ia. Hop. Îl iau.
Hai, Gabriel.
Da,
>> da,
>> da.
>> E mare, Gabi?
>> Nu e mare.
>> Filmez.
>> Hai, Alina. Așaina
pe
>> s a dus. Bă, dragi pescari, am mai avut
o trăsătură. L am simțit pentru 3 4
secunde, după care s a eliberat.
Mecanica este ok. a cârligului.
Singurul Singura explicație este modul
de hrănire. Se hrănește greu, este
apatic. Ați văzut, nu [muzică] știu,
sper că se vede bine pe filmare cum o
țăcăne un pic, o țăcăne un pic. A plecat
un pic cu ea. Am încercat să înțep din
ciupiturile respective. L am simțit un
pic, dar na, asta e. Poate că m am
grăbit un pic. Poate trebuia să las mai
mult. Dar Marius dă din cap face. Adică
că m am grăbit.
>> [râsete]
>> Da. Deci, continuăm. Al doilea
a doua ratare pe locul acesta. E bine că
avem activitate. E bine că avem
trăsături că activitate, n am scos
nimic. Hai să vedem ce se mai întâmplă.
Dragi pescari, astăzi este 10 pentru
pește. Un singur pește am reușit să
scoatem astăzi. În rest, niște plătici,
o mreană. Nu am reușit să scoatem nimic
mai mare. Am avut două trăsături pe
acest loc. cu una 100% de pește mare s a
lăsat pe ea. Ați văzut pe filmare. A
doua am simțit peștele timp de 3
secunde, după care s a eliberat. Am
vorbit și cu Harry și a reparat barca. A
reușit să ajungă și el pe unul dintre
canalele de pe lângă Mila 23.
Într o oră a avut șase șase pești scoși
între două și 5 kg zice el. Acuma, na,
nu știm ce să facem mâine. Dacă să
mergem tot aici, să venim tot aici,
pentru că locul este înădit și, na, în
trecut ne a dat pește mare și ne a dat
pește suficient. Sau să mergem pe
canale, nu știu, vedem. Ne punem mâine
la masă. Ne punem în seara asta la masă
și cu Harry, mă consult și cu Marius și
vedem ce o să facem. Așa că stați cu noi
să vedem mâine dacă este 2.0 sau 1 1.
Dragi pescari, a început o ploaie
torențială. Ne pregăteam să plecăm de pe
locul de pescuit. L am sunat pe Harry.
Hari mi a zis: "Vezi că la noi plouă
torențial. Ne am băgat în chesoane, tot
ce putea să se ude și o luăm spre
cazare. Ăsta i pescuitul Delta Dunării.
Asta ne place.
>> Bună dimineața, dragi pescari! Am ieșit
la pescuit în a doua zi de pescuit. De
data aceasta am ales să ieșim pe noapte.
Am riscat un pic. Am mers pe întuneric
pentru că am vrut să avem cât mai multe
ore de pescuit. Ăă, astăzi o să stăm pe
canale, pe canalele din jurul milei 23.
O să încercăm să prindem ceva crapi. Ăă,
iar mâine dimineață când plecăm vrem să
mai încercăm la pește mare pe sulina, pe
locul pe care l am nădit ieri și pe care
am pescuit ieri. Ieri a fost o zi în
care am prins un singur crap, umbreană,
câteva plătici. A fost 10 pentru pește
și vedem ce se întâmplă astăzi. O să
încep să filmez drillurile,
dacă o să am drilluri, bineînțeles, de
când se luminează, pentru că acuma este
întuneric și nu știu cât de bine aș
putea să aș putea să le filmez. Hai,
stați cu mine până la final să vedem ce
se întâmplă. Dragi pescari, am avut o
trăsătură la lanseta din stânga pe
peletă de 10 mm,
dar văd că n a luat o.
Îl lăsăm. Ia să strângem un pic să
vedem.
Îl lăsăm, nu l grăbim.
Oricum se hrănesc destul de apatic.
Și vedem, poate se întoarce și o ia din
nou.
Aha.
Îl iau Marius.
Îl iau că am impresia că s a dus cu ea
așa.
Vezi firul?
Eu
cred că e cu ea în scenal. Ia fii atent.
>> Eu cred că e cu ea în scenal. Cred că a
luat o și a venit spre mine.
Asta a făcut sigur.
Dragi pescari, [râsete]
primul crap al partidei de astăzi.
Uitați vă și voi un ciortănel de câteva
zeci de grame.
Dacă asta avem pe VAD, nu e bine.
Oricum, o să stăm maxim până la ora 9:00
și dacă n avem o trăsătură mai bună,
dacă nu prindem ceva, ne mutăm.
Mai pregătim o pungă de nadă. De data
asta o să folosim căpșună cu mixul de
pelete de 5 mm pe care le amestecăm, le
punem direct în găleată, punem o pungă
de nadă și un sfert de pungă de pelete
de 5 mm. Le umectăm bine bine. Le lăsăm
să tragă, după care când luăm și punem
pe momitor, o frământăm un pic în mână
dacă este suficient de umedă. Dacă nu,
ud mâna bag mâna în apă. iau cantitatea
pe care o vreau s o pun pe momitor. O
frământ un pic în mână, după care o pun
pe momitor.
Este foarte simplu de prepara nada de
sălbatic.
Cam asta trebuie să fie textura nadei
când o preparăm. Da, o să fie suficient
de umedă. Ea oricum o să și tragă, mai
ales că avem și peletele care peletele o
să tragă destul de multă apă și după
care ea o să rămână cum trebuie.
Cred că aduc cu un ciortan încă ceva.
Uite cum îl aduc.
Ciortan. Ia uite, Hari, ce mare e ăsta.
>> Ciortan.
Deci e clar că pe vadă avem numai
ciortan,
ciortănașii din acesta mic. O să ne
mutăm locul pentru că nu facem nimic
aici.
Este și Honey cu noi, este puțin mai
sus. A scos și el unul la fel și unul la
1,g.
Dar noi îi căutăm pe ăia mai mari.
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> Gata, ne am mutat. Ne am mutat din locul
unde am prins ciorteleia mici. Am venit
pe tot pe același canal, pe o altă zonă.
Am sondat cu sonarul. Am văzut ceva peși
mai mari în fața noastră. Avem multe
multe cioate în apă. Sunt copacii
practic de pe vizavi pe care îi vedeți
acolo. Unii sunt rupți, la alții le au
căzut crengi și am văzut pești printre
crengile respective. Acum, na, așteptăm
să vedem ce se întâmplă. Cum am lansat,
am avut o trăsătură la lanseta asta. A
luat a luat un pic
a s a lăsat un pic pe ea, după care i a
dat drumul. Să vedem ce se întâmplă.
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> Dă i drumul la filmare.
Aha.
În sfârșit a venit și la noi unul.
Îl ținem.
Avem cioate în față și tragem un pic mai
tare de el
până iese de acolo.
Îl aducem mai aici și aici ne jucăm cu
el.
Așa.
Oha!
Ia să vedem, dragi ho! Ia uitați
frumusețe. Ia uite frumusețe.
Da.
Ia uitați vă la pelete de 10 mm.
Ia uitați vă și voi ce frumusețe.
Vai de capul meu.
Superb.
Bine.
Deci uitați vă cum stau
în cioătură
a venit după o oră de când le am
aruncat.
Dar uitați vă ce frumos e.
>> Pasa de cap.
>> Da, dar vezi pe zona asta nu până în
ciudat aia. Nu știu. Să nu dai
niciodată.
>> Nu dau aici la jumate că n
>> Păi nu, mă, ce dai la jumate că nu te
legi de nimic. De jumate trebuie să dai
mai în față ca să fie pe linia lor. Deci
fii atent. Gata aia unde ținea pești. E
aici în dreptul la în dreptul la ăsta
așa și ține așa. Ai înțeles? Aici era.
Aici aici ținea peștii. Pe zona asta
acolo n am văzut niciun pește. Așa. Și
un
>> m Eu aș zice s o mut pe asta de aici, s
o dau așa, s o dai fix aici pe mijloc,
drept, dar nu departe. Deci nu departe.
Da. Adică nu până nu până unde se
termină ăla, cum ar veni. Mai mai spre
noi un pic.
>> Deci trecut de jumate a c
>> trecut de jumate mai în față. Laura,
am prins mai devreme un pește și vom
face din nou nădire. Aici în găleata
asta am combinat bilele de 24, Delta
Activ și Delta Secret.
Delta Secret ul este semisolubil, iar
Delta Activ este solubil și o să facem
din nou nădire. Am nădit și în cioată,
deci am dat bile și direct în cioată și
pe lângă cioată cumva pe linia unde noi
unde noi lansăm o dată ca să dea de
gustul lor în cioată și să vrea să caute
și altele. Să vrea să na să iasă de
acolo, iar noi să l prindem pe pe zona
unde pescuim. Mai fac din nou nădire,
mai arunc câteva bile, câteva mâini de
bile și tot așa o s o țin până când
plecăm de pe locul de pescuit.
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> N am mai avut nicio trăsătură pe locul
acesta, deși l am nădit. N am nădit
niciodată. Am lădit pe lângă. Ieșim un
pic cu barca să ne uităm să vedem dacă
mai este pește în fața noastră. Ă și
mergem să căutăm și alte locuri să vedem
unde este peștele cantonat.
Acum ce am văzut astăzi față de ieri și
de alalte ieri, peștele pe care l am
găsit aici era tot cantonat într o
cioată. Era tot băgat într o ciată în
ramurile acelei cioate, ceea ce ieri și
alalte ier nu s a întâmplat lucrul
acesta. unde am văzut pește, unde am
văzut crap, era pe praguri sau era pe
lângă cio? Adică cumva se plimba. Ok, o
să ies cu sonarul să văd care i treaba,
dacă și a modificat comportamentul și
încercăm să prindem și alții.
>> [muzică]
[muzică]
>> Neața, dragi pescari! A treia zi de
pescuit. Am pierdut dimineață două ore
pe canale. Am fost pe Îngusta, am fost
pe Bogda Proste, am sandat ambele canale
doar pe Îngusta am văzut ceva ciortan și
câțiva carași. În rest, nimic. După care
am venit pe Dunărea Mare, pe sulina, pe
locul care a fost nădită trei zile la
rând. Este ultima zi, sunt ultimele ore
de pescuit, 3 4 ore. O să stăm până la
ora 12:00 și sperăm să luăm ceva aici.
Dacă nu vom lua nimic, asta este. Ăsta
este pescuitul. Am venit într o perioadă
în care peștele nu s a hrănit și
bineînțeles că nu este o scuză pe care
pe care o spun acum. Dar dacă sunteți
pescari și ați pescuit în Delta Dunării,
știți despre ce vorbesc. Sunt perioade
în care peștele nu se hrănește bine,
sunt perioade în care nu găsești peștele
și atunci automat nu prinzi pește. Una
peste alta, chiar dacă peștele nu s a
hrănit bine, am reușit să scoatem trei
crap până acum la poze. Am avut și o
mană. Na, cam asta a fost. Ieri am
pescuit pe canale. Am pescuit pe un
canal de lângă mila la 23. Am găsit trei
cioate unde peștii erau acolo. Erau
băgați în cioată. O singură ceată,
la o singură ceată l am văzut la un
moment dat că ieșea cumva și în fața
cioatei. Ia, am făcut nădire, ați văzut
pe pe filmare, am făcut nădire, am nădit
în cioată, am nădit pe lângă cioată doar
doar doar să l scoatem de acolo și ieri
am reușit să scoatem doi pești. Unul
este pe filmare, unul nu este pe
filmare. Rămăsesem fără baterie la
cameră. A filmat mai cu telefonul un pic
și n am reușit să i l pozez pentru că
când am încercat să l ridic la poză să l
pozez a scăpat. Dar na, asta este.
Oricum n a fost n a fost o frecvență
bună pe pește. Harry a prins și el ieri
trei pești, a prins și unul mai măricel
pe canale. Na, s a ciugulit. Am foarte
multe cunoștințe în Delta Dunării. În
momentul de față în stânga mea este
Andrei.
În dreapta, mă rog, în stânga mea, cum
stau așa, este
Andrei, în dreapta este Iulian. Nici ei
n au prins niciun pește. Iulian m a
sunat dimineață și m a întrebat, zice:
„Gabi, ia zi, ai făcut ceva? Că dacă nu,
eu am stat degeaba aici și vreau să mă
duc la caras. Cam asta este situația.
Sunt multe bărci. Am vorbit cu mai mulți
pe Sky, deci nu s a prins mai pe
nicăieri. Na, așteptăm. Suntem pe locul
acesta. Dacă intră ceva astăzi, mă
declar fericit, mă declar norocos. Dacă
nu intră
data viitoare
am s o scot pe asta din stânga. Nu are
un
o plătică ceva.
Să bag și pe astea mobile,
Marisică.
Păi da.
Aveam două pe momitor și pe pelete și le
schimbăm pe bile cu plumb pierdut pentru
că
momitorul atrage peștele mic și n are
sens cel puțin pe locul ăsta aici să
continuăm cu ele. He.
[muzică]
Dragi pescari, trăsătură,
un run frumos. S a lăsat pe ea
și s a eliberat.
Este 11:30. Mai avem jumătate de oră și
plecăm acasă. Se pare că partida asta nu
este a noastră. Peștele nu a colaborat
absolut deloc cu noi sau
avem foarte mulți urmăritori care ne au
urat baftă. [râsete]
Gata, dragi pescari, partida noastră
este aproape gata. Mai stăm 10 minute și
strângem lansetele. Am zis să fac așa o
încheiere
cum se cuvine.
M am pus, am luat camera și m am pus cu
spatele pentru că bate vântul.
Încerc să țin microfonul cât mai ferit
de vânt ca să se și audă ceva. Bun, deci
cam asta a fost partida. De data asta
peștele a câștigat. Am prins în trei
zile trei crapi. Ăștia au fost toți. Am
mai avut câteva trăsături și mai devreme
am avut o trăsătură, dar nu am reușit să
l scot.
Mă rog, nu s a înțepat bine, ceva s a
întâmplat și s a eliberat.
Am pescuit și pe canale, am pescuit și
pe
brațul principal, am întit.
Ideea e că am făcut din perspectiva mea,
din punctul meu de vedere, am făcut cam
tot ce ținea de mine ca pescar în
momentul de față. Peștele nu s a hrănit,
deși l am localizat
destul de bine pe canale, l am găsit pe
trei cioate.
Am încercat să l scot de acolo. Nu am
reușit să l scot. Am prins doar doi
pești.
Oricum, partida asta a început așa cu
ghinioane de la început. Barca lui Harry
s a stricat
și am mai avut așa mici ghinioane pe pe
parcurs. Acum a început vântul și bate
din sud. Noi ne ducem la la Nufăru, avem
barca la Nufăru. O să prindem toate
valurile alea de la Nufăru. Dar na, asta
este ce mai voiam să vă zic despre
pescuitul despre pescuitul în Delta
Dunării. Nu vreau să vă creați o imagine
falsă despre
pescuită, despre a prinde pește.
Eu încerc să postez și clipurile în care
nu avem partide spectaculoase.
De ce? Pentru că vreau să înțelegeți că
peștele este pește și oricât de mult am
vrea noi să l capturăm, oricât de multe
informații am avea, sunt partide în care
este posibil să nu prindem pește, dar nu
trebuie să ne supărăm.
Trebuie să învățăm din aceste partide.
Trebuie să ne punem întrebări de ce nu a
funcționat, ce nu a funcționat, ce aș fi
putut să fac mai bine și să îmbunătățim
mereu strategia pe care noi o aplicăm.
Momentan nu știu să vă zic ce aș fi
putut să îmbunătățesc în această partidă
pentru că încă nu m am gândit. Consider
că am făcut totul perfect, totul ca la
carte. Am pescuit unde a trebuit, am
localizat peștele și încă nu mi dau
seama, dar probabil
în drum spre casă, în mașină îmi voi da
seama de anumite aspecte pe care aș fi
putut să le fac mai bine. Bun, cam asta
este
ultima
nu este ultima partidă. Sper să mai fac
una în decembrie. Asta este ultima
partidă din luna noiembrie, la sfârșit
de noiembrie. Temperaturile au fost când
ridicate, când scăzute. Ier ne a fost
frig. că astăzi este relativ ok. Acum
trei zile a fost cald. Na, cam asta e.
Ce să zic? Vă mulțumesc frumos că ați
urmărit acest clip până la final și dacă
ați avut și voi o astfel de partidă în
care ați făcut tot ce a stat în puterile
voastre, dar totuși nu aș nu ați reușit
să prindeți pește, scrieți mi în
comentarii ca să văd că nu sunt
singurul. Bine, eu știu sigur că nu sunt
singurul. Vă salut și vă doresc fi
întins.